andré francis vous êtes le directeur
artistique de ce festival est ce qu'il
faut vraiment parler du jazz comme ça on
peut parler du gers comme ça on peut
avec toutes les bannières le chat c'est
tellement riche c'est tellement divers
que c'est aussi bien pour les
intellectuels que pour les gens simples
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on ne
l'envisagent pas d'une manière tout à
fait poétique et comme par visage pas
d'une manière tout à fait technique mais
ce qui a pas quand même deux clans les
érudits et puis les autres qui viennent
comme ça y'a bill clan il ya mille
sortes de jazz il ya mille musiciens de
jazz ya aucune raison que l'on soit
bloqué dans un petit domaine ce qui
compte c'est que la musique de jazz
aujourd'hui c'est la musique créative la
plus importante de ce siècle
ce n'est pas celle qui est réservé à une
petite élite ça se développe dans
tellement de domaines différents que
tout le monde peut y trouver son compte
et celui qui veut de la musique froide
intellectuelle pensée écrite et celui la
musique de sentiments
[Musique]